[Music]
okay so this is my spoiler review of
ready or not the mystery thriller that
also is a dark comedy it is one of those
movies that was getting a lot of
attention out of nowhere and that is
because it had a really good reception
by critics so you go in there with
expectations of like okay this is a
sleeper hit now this falls onto under my
problem with just Rotten Tomatoes as a
whole right now and I've been on this
ramp before but this is a classic
example of they give a movie a lot of
hype and it's because the meter says 89
percent fresh but that could just mean
there's a bunch of reviews that are
decent it doesn't mean it's actually a
really good movie or that eight means
it's an 8 on a scale it's just 80% of
people liked it it doesn't mean it's
that good and this was one of those
movies for me where I just kept my
expectations here and it was super
disappointing it does not live up to
this hype it's been given it makes it
seem like this is a game changer in this
genre and it is not and it's really
frustrating and it pisses me off because
I feel like people just see anything
that's a little unique to them and they
go crazy about it and I think all this
is a game changer this is awesome it's
cool and then we kind of just listen to
everybody else on it and to just follow
each other like sheep and this is just a
case right I just don't see how you
could think this is a great movie now
what I like about it the lead here
Samira weaving awesome she was a treat
yes the hype for her as an actress is
well-deserved
she is a rare natural here where she's
automatically likable on the screen you
root for her and she just has so much
charisma and I feel like a lot of
actresses in Hollywood right now who are
getting cast in roles that need charisma
which I was talking about a Captain
Marvel talking about Jessica Chastain
and it
sameer weaving has that charm so it's
nice to see that fresh face that can put
on different ammo
and you feel all of it and she does that
perfectly in this movie so props to her
production design excellent looks so
cool they did the house really well and
the lighting here was spectacular that
obviously includes the cinematography
that was the highlights of the film for
me now always a script is the most
important to me and this is just another
paint by the number script it thinks
it's way clever then it actually is so
they just go off this concept you see of
just okay we're gonna play a game
there's a card that's bad in this whole
pile it's hide-and-seek and you have to
survive and that's some your weavings
character and you're watching this and
you're like okay so the adults have to
kill her and find her by Dawn it's a
very simple concept this movie was kind
of pitched by critics as in the movies
fault but that there's gonna be twisty
or suspenseful or just keeping you
engaged and it just does not because
it's actually really just a simple plot
and it tries to blend in comedy which I
think had moments I think that the
scenes with the niece where she's
accidentally killing people was really
funny that worked well other than that
it was kind of like and I mean there was
giggles in the theater so if you're
looking to just laugh out loud at dark
humor it's not the best you're gonna see
it's easy it's lazy and then if you're
looking for mystery everything is
predictable in this movie it you've seen
it all before and that's a big problem I
have here that you could everybody's
transparent you see right through it and
no characters here actually have depth
to them they're just all one character
type and that takes me out of it in the
sense of feeling like this is really
happy and this is intense or this is
crazy there's a lot of wait no it's like
you know who he is you know who he is
and you know who he is you knew right
from the second you saw Adam Brody on
screen he's this troubled soul brother
who is conflicted in where he stands
you knew the dad was a nut you knew the
mom was just going along with the ride
but understood the side of the girl here
and it was just like nothing changed on
any of these characters that's who they
were so I was really frustrating made it
way less interesting I think that there
was a lot of corny lines in here
particular when Alex the husband talks
to his mom and he's like if it comes
down to you or her I choose her talking
to his mom and I think the problem with
the characters here is that I didn't
actually feel like they really were a
family that's what pissed me off I think
the mother and Alex I was like oh yeah
that's his mom it just didn't feel that
type of relationship at points and they
kind of missed out on really making you
see this family and the drama between
them and that they're actually mom and
son I felt sort of too much like
strangers there which I did not think
helped at all in this story having said
that I do like the commentary this film
has in the theme about just traditions
family having to hold on to and they're
based off these fears that are just
ridiculous and it also did a good job
having that in the relationship here
with Alex and Samira weaving here and
that you know you get upset because your
in-laws and this happens relationships
because they won't let go of these
traditions or close-minded thoughts and
they use it as an excuse for bad
behavior and it also worked well here
with Alex where he just doesn't turn and
end up is and he ends up choosing his
family really over her in the end and
that some people that's just always
gonna be the weight and they weigh those
things out between lover and their own
family and a lot of times they choose
their own family even though they know
deep down it's the wrong choice or they
don't believe what their family says but
they have this thing just like instilled
in them they can't let go of it and it's
when you're almost blindly loyal to your
family so they did a really good job at
that theme that's what I appreciate
about the movie but man there was some
dragging scenes here particularly I'm
going to talk about when Samira is in
the kitchen and the butler is looking
for her that's he went on way too long
and it thought it was super suspenseful
and it wasn't she's just walking around
that cabinet while he's just chopping
something and that went on for a long
time and then another thing like that
was just the sequence of her in the barn
with the kid
it started off good but then she falls
down like this patch that scene was
ridiculously long and stretched out in a
short movie that can make it feel a drag
and it falls into this territory of
everything you've seen in Horrors before
which makes me like what was everyone
talking about perfect example you're
just seeing her jump over the fence get
out of there and a car rejects taking
her away and she decides to scream in
the middle of the road for everyone to
hear where she is which was just like
that was the point I was groaning like
come on here we go this is Harlequin and
what are we watching we're watching a
blonde girl run away from a butler for
about a half hour and then it ends up
her in bondage getting tortured in a
ritual it's everything you've seen
before this is nothing unique I'm sorry
this is so blown out of proportion just
pisses me off and then it's just her
getting really bloody it's it's just
paint by the numbers and it's getting
way too much credit as if it wasn't that
type of movie so I feel like that
concept of the game part for some reason
bailed them out of that where if it
didn't have that and good press behind
it this is just any other horror movie
you've seen on Netflix come on now now
another positive though I'll give it is
I did like if there was some kind of
cool twist that they actually were right
and that at dawn everyone exploded that
was cool I thought that worked it was
also funny and it was a nice touch at
the end of her smoking a cigarette and
I'm just saying in the inlaws so I'll
give it props for that but overall I
don't know if this even makes sense for
this movie is a red herring it is not
what you think it is that it's this
groundbreaking horror movie like a get
out it's not that
so please please just realize that and
be above the sheep and the herd if
people are just thinking everything's
great everything's groundbreaking
everything's good come on let's let's be
real here
but again I'm excited to see Samira
leaving and more stuff I think a fair
score for this would be a 6.1 not good
it's just okay and it's definitely
passable in my eyes so let me know if
you thought of it down below are you on
board with everyone saying this is a
groundbreaking movie I'd love to hear
your thoughts on it or maybe you agree
with me and you
see it as overhyped Peru a lot of these
movies that are coming out right now in
Hollywood so yeah let me know in the
comments below please follow me at Steve
Varley one on Twitter Instagram for more
of me and I'll see you next time